oh i love being a woman when did you
start loving being of being a woman when
you were fat or when you were skinny
because it's giving me fat phobia my god
remember when i told you about the adele
story yeah like how loud if it was fake
and whatnot adele is basically a pop
star so she's in the news basically for
transphobia right what she said on the
brit awards so
i like to have
context
because i i find like a lot of people on
youtube what they do is they take a
snippet of someone's video and say oh
that person is transphobic so at the end
of the award right
they used to have best
male category and best female category
but because they wanted to be inclusive
they got rid of the male and the female
right
keep up
so you know adele take her big ass up to
the stage
because now she's dating a black man so
you know she's got to be a little
transphobic right
[Laughter]
no
where'd that transition come
from wow yeah yeah yeah yeah you know i
was i was messing with this broad right
we take it up to my bedroom and then all
of a sudden i'm starting to suck this
bitch's dick right and you're like what
what just happened me can i appreciate
the thing that happened is this all
right i'm gonna tell you this
i should have saw the sign cause
when you finish your sentences and you
clap your hands
you about to turn left
that's what happened i thought i
suspected it was gonna get a little bit
pity because she said she took her fat
ass to the stage so you know adele take
her big ass up to the stage
i said poof
okay and i was like
maybe she just gotta have a fat ass so
i'm gonna let that slide because now
she's dating a black man so you know
she's gotta be a little transphobic
right because you know what black men
brings straight black men bring to the
community
transphobia all the jazz if adele was
with a white guy this [ __ ] would not
happen
nah nah nah nah nah nah nah hoy
no no i refuse
i refuse okay
you almost hurt yourself there because i
really wish
you stretched before you did that reach
thousa that's a reach
that's a reach girlfriend
that's a reach
oh my god
yo you
you know what no no you know what i owe
fresh and fish in a fresh infinite pouch
it's not even their fault that they
saying anytime black stuff they've been
getting with these becky's right because
they've if they would have been with the
shaniquas they wouldn't have been saying
this stuff
that doesn't work like that how cause it
was the patriarchy talking
everything everything is our fault
[ __ ] can be at home chilling by
themselves
a woman can be saying i'm proud to be a
female
black men our fault
but
let me continue
so
adele
basically said out of her mouth the name
of this award has changed but i really
love being a woman and being a female
artist i do
i do so basically you guys heard her she
said i understand that the award is
changed to gender fluid
but
i love being a woman i love being a
female
adele
you know damn well
you were trying to
lick gunshots
on
gender fluid people and the trans
community you know that it's gonna push
the envelopes girl it's not the trans
people's fault while your show got
cancelled in vegas
okay okay hold up she never even blamed
y'all
she scares the show in vegas she had to
cancel her residency because of the fact
that they couldn't prep the show because
so many people were locked down getting
sick so it was hard to actually prep a
show to put on that's what she said
nothing to do with trans folks i don't
know where this came from that link okay
that so-called context that you wanted
to find you threw that [ __ ] in the trash
can okay
i'm not a female
that's facts
but i could imagine that there are
certain struggles that female artists
face
that can make their trajectory towards
the top be different so i could
understand that when she gets up there
she has an award she's like damn in
spite of all the [ __ ] i have to go
through as a female trying to make it as
an artist right that i'm still here i
can understand that's part of her entire
experience
so for you to be like this is a jab at
us that's crazy to me
i'm gonna say it's consistent with
what we've already said in the past
yeah and i've already told you in the
past tell them
it's not my fight i'm not part of that
discussion
i stopped being part of that discussion
a long time ago i'm not the one who's
gonna have to deal with that
that's not me
that's y'all
so don't take your anger out on trans
people
like girl you didn't you didn't you
didn't have to be extra and you didn't
have to put your trauma out on other
people who were not talking about you
you talking about adele's projecting
you're projecting boo-boo she didn't
even mention y'all she had nothing to
say about you that's it
when
when someone is triggered
there's there's no point
sense is not there it's not the sense
it's the triggers that talk that's what
i'm saying i don't understand it's okay
but what i'm saying is like i learned
that
you reasoning or trying to reasoning
with them it's not going to happen i'm
not i'm not doing this to respond to her
specifically this is for the viewers
yeah absolutely i mean what she wants
she want to live in la la land and be
delusional that's her right that's her
prerogative right the main thing is if
you get on these platforms and you say
something crazy folks you should be able
to just be able to say this is why what
you said it's nice this is why that's
why wow definitely i'm gonna [ __ ] get
up here talk about i'm proud to be black
and somebody else would be like uh i
feel like you were trying to take a shot
at white people in the greater american
public by not identifying first as an
american who cares like yo man just shut
up maybe that's part of their experience
and i won't talk about that who cares i
would have also had the same energy if a
trained and artist got up there and said
i'm proud to be a trans artist and to
win this award yeah i'm elated and if
some females got mad they'd be like
excuse me as a cis woman let me shut
your ass up she won't be proud to be a
trans woman to be a gay artist like how
many gay artists have gone on black i'm
proud to be i don't give a [ __ ] let's go
i don't care let's go
so if the brit awards decides hey we
want to be more inclusive
why are you taking your big ass
on stage
oh i love being a woman when did you
start loving being of being a woman when
you were fat or when you were skinny
because it's giving me fat phobia my god
but i think this is not gonna get better
i think we're good like my god what does
this have to do what the [ __ ] you know
what this probably needs to be a
separate video but the amount of people
that are upset at dove for losing weight
is crazy it is scary like how mad they
are her from making a healthy decision
that's insane to me because it's giving
me fat phobia
because you weren't saying you loved
being a woman when you were 250 pounds
but now you 150
you love being a woman
girl we know we i'm not saying that
she's trying so big but she wanted to
lick shots
she wanted to fire shots at the trans
community we know this
just walk in your transphobia walk in
your turf ism
i'm not saying you're transphobic but uh
you can walk in your transphobic heels
and enjoy strutting around like the
devil wears prada uh [ __ ] uh hello
adele from the other side how does it
feel to be a trans woman now
cause yesterday you was cool you was fat
today you were skinny you were turf we
got a problem
oh you want to give a shout out to your
son uh is he black because he's probably
anti-trans too how was that [ __ ] dick
yeah
you got that masculine energy in you you
got that patriarchy in you good
good it's good how's that [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i've been watching the wrong
kind of porn yeah
yeah yeah yeah have you ever gone uh
pornhub they got a turf category it's
pretty much interracial so
i'm just saying this to me
is mad
it's crazy this this is unhinged yeah
it's crazy this is unhinged this is like
seeing things that aren't there no
for me i'd rather someone just say yo i
do not like trans people
i'm a turf
i respect jk rowling than these
undercover turfs you get insane and i'm
not saying that adele is
a turf you know sometimes there's a
difference between someone not liking
you and not liking trans people like
you're dislikable right just based off
this video i'm just saying summarizing
but i could see why someone could say i
don't like you
you don't always have to link it to the
fact that you're trained sometimes
you're just a shitty person who happens
to be trans
right there's some black people that i
hate
it's not because they're black it's not
sulfate no sometimes it's just because
they're fresh and fit right that's what
happens it's not because they're
blackness there's a difference between
the two things right there can be people
you really dislike that's okay
yeah you have the right thing but it's
not because of their identity or what
that has nothing to do with that
she's given turf light cause girl we
know you're a woman
we know that you love being a woman
but the award title was gender fluid
why didn't you say you loved being a
woman when you got the first
award
why didn't you say you love being a
woman when you got the second award you
waited for the gender neutral award to
make the comments
girl
catch the tea maybe it's because when
she lost her weight she recognizes how
much of a negative influence everybody
had on her body image how everyone felt
beholden to her body because she was a
female maybe she became more cognizant
of her sex within this industry as she
began to have more and more body issues
over time and realize how insidious a
lot of this stuff is sometimes you're
not cognizant of your identity until it
becomes an issue within whatever realm
that you live in right
that happens to people so then you'll be
like damn you know in spite of but i'm
not gonna repeat myself man this [ __ ]
right here makes me want to go take a
[ __ ]
she's been thinking of [ __ ] in this
[ __ ] video this whole time
and this is why you see all of these
people who do not like trends on youtube
they're oh
this is why the trans community is going
crazy and then you have like
women
especially black women oh why don't we
never hear from the trans man is it
because of misogyny because trans women
are so loud and like to take over spaces
um the spaces are for us girl
the last time i check trans women are
women
trans women are not female but trans
women are women so we're gonna be in
women's spaces whether you like it or
not so you're not proud to be a woman
huh
she's a woman right
adele's a woman
okay she's a woman right it does a proud
to be a woman
maybe she's referring to you too
aren't you proud to be a woman too he'll
be mad at that one i mean no
i don't disagree whether you like it or
not
sis is going to be in women's faces
did your black boyfriend tell you to say
that
because we know there's a lot of a lot
of
oh tips
right that you white girls love you guys
love these oteps right by definition a
hotep is not gonna go out with a white
girl
how this is just nonsense it's nonsense
and we're gonna see more of this um so
just buckle up folks
but yeah i just have to watch myself to
not get triggered by any of this and be
like
number five
tess chris not your fight it's not your
fight it's not your fight yeah it's okay
it doesn't have to be a [ __ ] oh i don't
sometimes you just drop in a bra
yeah you just gotta you see two girls
pulling each other's hair sometimes
you'll be like yo can i get a kicking
no never happened to you no no you've
never seen two videos you'd be like i'll
rip your hair up and you just like punt
that's my girlfriend
what do you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you let us
know do you agree disagree can you be
proud to be a woman